in my opinion i think this is a
direction culturally we need to go is to
continue to uh be able to get to
ourselves to awareness to our feelings
and to our intuition and so i was
thinking about you know the story of the
baby and you know being a greedy baby at
just you know a few months old
but from my researching especially from
bruce lipton that the human subconscious
is programmed from
they say the last trimester
of pregnancy on
so
it feels to me like there's a
possibility and i don't i don't hear you
arguing i i hear you saying you're not
sure if there's true malevolence or not
um but it seems like there are some
supposedly some studies that that would
sort of say people are genetically
different but i wonder if instead of it
being sort of a participation in in
actions it's an energetic exchange that
creates the monster the greedy baby
you mean you mean the baby in the last
trimester was picking up something from
the mother
that's an interesting theory i've never
heard anything about i don't know how
anybody can prove it but i'm sure there
is
because they've done studies where
they um they've the mother plays certain
classical music or certain music for the
baby and it in you know in the last
trimester it has a definite effect on
them so i'm sure there's some some
validity to that yeah
but i mean still i still would maintain
that there's probably a genetic
component that that is underlying it
even then
that even even prior to that trimester
there are things that are that are going
on that are underneath there that we'll
never ever really know i mean
if you study human nature in psychology
like the people you refer to that the
great book
i'm not on their level but i've studied
it for many years you develop a bit of
humility because humans are so complex
complicated and if you spend one minute
analyzing yourself and analyzing the
degrees of emotions you can have in
three minute period and how your mind
will go from this that and the other you
begin to appreciate the incredible
complexity of the human being which is
why i'm very skeptical about things like
artificial intelligence because i don't
think you can ever replicate the
incredible complexity of the human brain
and the incredible complexity of our
nature how we can feel things and
understand things not through
necessarily
rational appreciation but through
intuition
intuition is an incredible part of our
knowledge and our ability to get
anything done you can't probe that into
machine
so
i don't have the answers about this
genetic component or not i sort of am
humbled by the fact that
there's so many mysteries about human
nature that i don't think we'll ever
understand because we're this marvelous
creation
the human brain as i'm discussing in my
next book
is the most complex organism in the
entire universe the number of cells the
number of neuronal connections in the
brain
far surpassed the number of
of stars in in the universe of the uh
you know it's just it's an incredible
thing about our brains are just
unbelievable
so i don't think i can ever really
completely understand it and i come to
the subject with a degree of i'm trying
to understand it and there's still
mysteries that i'll never be able to
solve i think that's part of the human
experience that makes it interesting yet
frustrating and so it kind of leads me
into asking about this book because i
think i heard you it's based on
basically the big bang right and sort of
the trajectory after that and is that is
this correct and like trying to
understand and explore people's limited
thinking
um is that is that right is that the
book you're alluding to my new book when
i'm writing right now yeah yeah i mean i
have parts of it in in the daily laws in
the month of december well basically
it's a book i call it about the sublime
and i have this idea about human nature
that i've had for many many years and
the idea is that i kind of compare it to
a circle
that human beings naturally live inside
of a circle and that circle is this is
what you're supposed to think in your
culture this is how you're supposed to
behave there are rules they're
conventions you're not supposed to think
these kinds of thoughts you're supposed
to think these other ones
and that circle existed in ancient egypt
it didn't have the same
things that we have but it still was a
limitation you're not supposed to think
this in ancient egypt you're supposed to
behave this way it's changed the content
but that physical reality is the same
the moment you praise limits for the
human being they're fascinated by what
lies beyond it's part of our nature we
like what's supposedly transgressive
we're not supposed to go there we want
to go there you've ever had a
two-year-old you say no don't do that or
a cat don't go there that's where they
go the moment your back has turned right
not to say the cats have the same nature
as humans but they kind of do
anyway so
i'm saying that what lies outside that
circle is what i call the realm of the
sublime and i want people to begin to
think outside of that to expand their
minds to expand their consciousness to
not live in the sort of narrow little
world of your smartphone of what people
are telling you how you're supposed to
think and feel but to expand your mind
to other possibilities of looking at the
world
so i explained in the first chapter
about the big bang and the cosmos
and and the story of
the evolution of our universe
and first of all if you explore it
through through physics it's a lot of
science
it's the most insanely amazing beautiful
story that you could ever put together
it's so unlikely the way things ended up
becoming the way they are to see how
stars evolved to see how
our galaxy evolved how our solar system
how the sun was born and then how the
earth broke off from this kind of big
block of of rock and that how
our earth collided with another planet
some
i don't know how many billion four
billion early on in our history and that
collision created the moon
and you know
it's it's an unbelievably beautiful
story and it'll make you realize
that you're thinking here of your own
day-to-day affairs you're only thinking
about instagram etc
and yet this is this thing's been going
on for 13 billion years
it'll blow your mind it'll expand your
thinking it'll make you appreciate
just being alive it'll make you
appreciate that we have a son that we
have light that we have water
it'll change your thinking to expand
your mind outside the narrow circle that
we inhabit i have each chapter is about
that
a chapter about evolution about how
humans evolve which is an insane another
insane story i have a chapter about
ancient history and how
old religions had a different way of
looking at the human being that are
incredibly interesting and beautiful i'm
writing a chapter now on childhood and
how the world of children and their
minds are very different from adults and
how it's extremely exciting how you once
used to think when you were three years
old you have no access to how you were
thinking when you were three because you
it's so different from how you think now
you're not even aware of it but you
lived in this really surreal
amazing world where your senses were so
open
the child's brain is completely very
different from the adult brain and it's
kind of fascinating to study so i go
into that and how you can access your
childhood more easily as you're as an
adult so that's
you know animals how insane animals are
and how their consciousness is actually
quite related to our own on and on and
on so that's sort of the book that i'm
working on like what are the spinning
thoughts that you've had for some time
about this idea of how unlikely it is
that we're here how
you know miraculous the whole experience
is or maybe a better question is what do
you hope
to find
in writing the book that will then be
the message that you hope people get
from reading it well i'll tell you it's
it's weird thing it's a little bit
personal but i'll go into it originally
i intended the book as kind of a therapy
for you to kind of get you outside of
your yourself
because we get so self-absorbed that it
makes us it turns us off from the
wonders of our world i know that sounds
like a bit of a cliche but it is an
incredibly wondrous world that is around
us and we tend to get as we get older we
our circle gets narrower and narrower
and narrower so i thought of it as a
book of therapy
but honestly what happened is um
about three years ago i had a stroke
and um my life suddenly hit a wall
i was very athletic i mean i'm not i'm
not an athlete but i was i swam every
almost every day
mountain biked
hiked etc etc that was my whole that was
really
an integral part of who i am
all of that taken away
and so
a lot of people are in that situation in
life
right
they don't have a lot of money they're
not traveling to exotic locations they
have a job they don't necessarily like
i want to bring this books to the that
anybody it's going to have that kind of
therapeutic effect where you're you may
not be trapped by an injury like i am
but you're trapped by something else and
i want you you can heal some of that
through your mind through how you think
and my i have an idea in the book that
your mind either kind of contracts
or expands to what you think about
right you control that if you're only
thinking about your instagram account or
something like that that mind will
narrow narrow and narrow but if you're
thinking about
all these other issues that i'm talking
about about evolution about what it
means to be human about our relationship
to animals about nature about the brain
itself
your mind is expanding and it's it'll
have a
i hope a therapeutic impact on you
[Music]